yeah that guy was a weird guy to talk to
because i couldn't get over all the
stuff he does i'm like how do you do all
these different things
how do you make these and then you make
roof panels
and then you like drill in tunnels and
then you're shooting rockets into space
spacex yeah like he's doing everything
he's just gonna be the alien
she said he was maybe she listened
said he was an alien he might be
it might be a higher thinking life well
he might as well be
right if he was an alien and he looked
exactly like that i'll be honest when he
grabbed a joint and the way he kind of
looked at it i was kind of like it
seemed kind of like a guy who was kind
of like um i'm not familiar with this
practice but or maybe he's so smart
that he thought it would be funny if he
pretended he didn't know what a joint
was
could be i don't think he didn't know
what it was i'm just saying as he was
about to partake he kind of had this
real inquisitive like
yeah but there was a part it was a blunt
and he almost seemed like he didn't know
what a blunt was
like you've never been i could believe
that really i can believe that
the glass tip could have thrown him off
because that's a little unique if you're
not if you're not familiar
not everybody is hip to weed culture man
as we think
you know i mean right but when he said
that uh
tesla was going private funding secure
at 4 20.
which is he paid 20 million dollars for
that joke
that joe cost him 20 million dollars the
sec got mounted and they find them
yeah well it's also manipulating your
stock prices a little bit
well that was one of the things you can
send your shareholders into a panic
jamie was concerned that they were going
to contact us and see if we
arranged that pot smoking part
like if that was something that had been
arranged in advance because it crashed
the stock
and i was like i read all the stories
that was i was like joe rogan
making noise out of here i was like oh
jesus we didn't do that did we i
definitely didn't
yeah that was organic folks dude that
was amazing dude that was amazing
strange that's that's what this
podcast is for yeah for strange [ __ ]
strange
strange moments you can't get on nbc